I want to go over the most common forms
of meditation how each of them work what
benefits each bring and also who each of
them are for the next form of meditation
on our list is guided meditation how
does it work well basically this is any
form of meditation where a narrator is
guiding you through the process you
simply follow their instructions and
that's basically it the meditation
sessions can vary greatly depending on
the video or app that you're using what
sort of benefits does this form of
meditation bring I would definitely say
that this form of meditation is the
easiest form and that's because you
don't really have to deal with complete
silence and the doubts that come when
practicing meditation by yourself who is
this form of meditation for
guided meditation is something you
should consider if you've tried other
forms of meditation but felt like it was
too difficult there's no harm in putting
on some training wheels and getting used
to sitting still for extended periods of
time before eventually moving on to more
advanced forms of meditation follow us
for more helpful tips